For all the things that Charles Dickens’
“A Christmas Carol” is known for, Tiny
Tim, a relatively minor character in terms
of appearances in the story (but, importantly,
one of wholesome heart despite his physical
condition), was one of the characters that
Dickens wanted people to pay the most attention
to.
After all, he wrote “A Christmas Carol”
to bring more attention to the plight of the
children of the poor- a subject Dickens was
extremely passionate about owing to his own
experience with poverty as a child.
Dickens was born on February 7, 1812 in rural
England to a middle class family turned impoverished
when his father, a clerk named John, mismanaged
his finances and ended up being sent to Marshalsea
debtors’ prison.
As was the practice at the time, most of the
family joined him in jail – but not so for
Charles, who was deemed old enough to make
his own way in the world.
The 12 year old boy was moved into cheap lodgings
away from his family, removed from school,
and sent to Warren’s Shoe Blacking Factory.
His job there was to spend six days per week
pasting labels on jars of shoe polish.
His weekly pay for this was six shillings
(about £22 or $29 today) with which he had
to entirely support himself on.
Beyond having to endure insanely long work
hours at a monotonous task, he also was subjected
to appalling work conditions, including the
occasional physical abuse.
However, it was the psychological trauma of
the situation, and that nobody seemed at all
even mildly interested in his plight, that
Dickens would later lament the most when describing
what he considered the low point of his life:
It is wonderful to me how I could have been
so easily cast away at such an age.
It is wonderful to me that, even after my
descent into the poor little drudge I had
been since we came to London, no one had compassion
enough on me- a child of singular abilities,
quick, eager, delicate, and soon hurt, bodily
or mentally- to suggest that something might
have been spared, as certainly it might have
been, to place me at any common school.
Our friends, I take it, were tired out.
No one made any sign.
My father and mother were quite satisfied.
They could hardly have been more so if I had
been twenty years of age, distinguished at
a grammar-school, and going to Cambridge.
The blacking-warehouse was the last house
on the left-hand side of the way, at old Hungerford
Stairs.
It was a crazy, tumble-down old house, abutting
of course on the river, and literally overrun
with rats.
Its wainscoted rooms, and its rotten floors
and staircase, and the old grey rats swarming
down in the cellars, and the sound of their
squeaking and scuffling coming up the stairs
at all times, and the dirt and decay of the
place, rise up visibly before me, as if I
were there again.
The counting-house was on the first floor,
looking over the coal-barges and the river.
There was a recess in it, in which I was to
sit and work.
My work was to cover the pots of paste-blacking;
first with a piece of oil-paper, and then
with a piece of blue paper; to tie them round
with a string; and then to clip the paper
close and neat, all round, until it looked
as smart as a pot of ointment from an apothecary’s
shop.
When a certain number of grosses of pots had
attained this pitch of perfection, I was to
paste on each a printed label, and then go
on again with more pots.
Two or three other boys were kept at similar
duty down-stairs on similar wages.
One of them came up, in a ragged apron and
a paper cap, on the first Monday morning,
to show me the trick of using the string and
tying the knot.
His name was Bob Fagin; and I took the liberty
of using his name, long afterwards, in Oliver
Twist….
No words can express the secret agony of my
soul as I sunk into this companionship; compared
these every-day associates with those of my
happier childhood; and felt my early hopes
of growing up to be a learned and distinguished
man, crushed in my breast.
The deep remembrance of the sense I had of
being utterly neglected and hopeless; of the
shame I felt in my position; of the misery
it was to my young heart to believe that,
day by day, what I had learned, and thought,
and delighted in, and raised my fancy and
my emulation up by, was passing away from
me, never to be brought back any more; cannot
be written.
My whole nature was so penetrated with the
grief and humiliation of such considerations,
that even now, famous and caressed and happy,
I often forget in my dreams that I have a
dear wife and children; even that I am a man;
and wander desolately back to that time of
my life.
Deliverance from this fate came in the form
of John Dickens inheriting £450 upon the
death of John’s mother, Elizabeth Dickens.
With this money, the Dickens family was able
to get out of debtors’ prison (though John
would later end up back there again, and likely
many times, had it not been for Charles, due
to a habit of over spending).
This was not an immediate end to Charles’
miserable situation, however.
Rather than being returned to school, he was
forced to continue to work at the shoe blacking
factory for another year, apparently largely
due to his mother’s insistence, something
Dickens later would write of, “I never afterwards
forgot, I never shall forget, I never can
forget, that my mother was warm for my being
sent back.”
Eventually, however, he was allowed to quit
and go back to school.
After quick dalliances as a law clerk at the
age of 15 and later a theater actor, he became
a political journalist covering the House
of Commons.
At the same time, he also began to write his
first fiction pieces under the pseudonym of
“Boz” (a nickname family members had given
him).
His work began to gain traction, punctuated
by Dickens’ marriage to his book editor’s
daughter, Catherine, and the publishing of
Pickwick Papers – which both occurred in
April of 1836.
Two years later, he published Oliver Twist
and Dickens’ road to literary stardom was
paved.
In 1843, Dickens was only 31 years old and
already perhaps the most famous author of
his day.
Despite this, he was constantly in need of
money.
Much like his father before him, he had a
habit of seemingly always living at the limits
of his means.
Unlike his father, however, his means were
considerable and generally grew over time.
This was a good thing as he was also financially
responsible for a large family, which included
his wife, (eventually) ten children, a mistress,
brothers, sisters, and his parents.
Needless to say, even before all his children
arrived and he took up a mistress at the age
of 45, he wasn’t well prepared financially
to handle one of his works not selling well,
which is exactly what happened when he published
a serial beginning in 1842 that was a relative
flop – “Martin Chuzzlewit.”
While teetering on the edge of financial ruin,
a report came out, compiled by one of Dickens’
friends, Richard Henry Horne, that is today
considered one of the most important documents
in British industrial revolution history.
In short, the comprehensive Report of the
Children’s Employment Commission details
the extreme, unhealthy, dangerous, exploitative,
and just generally horrific working conditions
many poor children were forced to endure in
the UK.
The report did this in the most heartbreak
fashion- through countless first-hand testimonials
of the kids themselves.
Stories like teenager Isaac Tipton, who said
he started in the coal mines at seven years
old, working 12 hours a day, 6 days a week.
Over the course of his duties, he notes he
was regularly beaten by the older miners,
but “[I] deserved it…”
There were also more extreme reports of children
being killed or mangled owing to being treated
as disposable commodities, rather than human
beings.
For example, it outlines the practice of having
children climb into industrial machinery to
do things like remove jams, with the report
noting cases where removal resulted in the
child’s death when the machinery starting
again with them still inside of it.
On top of this, there were stories of young
girls working in garment factories sewing
with bleeding fingers- 16 hours per day, 6
days a week.
The most shocking thing of all brought to
light by the massive report was that these
conditions weren’t the exceptions, but more
the rule for the children of the poor in the
newly industrialized Britain.
The report also seemed to debunk by numerous
examples a commonly held idea about the poor-
that they were only poor because they were
lazy, drunks, inherently immoral, lacking
in intelligence, or were deformed in some
way.
Along this line of thinking, proposed government
aid to such individuals was intentionally
harsh- like the 1834 Poor Law Amendment Act,
which stopped government aid to the poor unless
they went to a workhouse, with said institutions
meant just as much to act as discouragement
from being poor as to actually help those
in need.
As such, as “Factory King” Richard Oastler
noted, workhouses essentially became “Prisons
for the Poor”.
Families were split in the workhouses and
the work provided was generally incredibly
grueling, with little food given to sustain
the occupants.
On top of that, workhouse masters were deliberately
cruel and abusive to those who resided in
their workhouse.
After all, if workhouse conditions were fully
humane, it only encouraged people to remain
lazy and immoral, which was of course the
cause of their being poor in the first place…
As you might imagine from all this, there
were frequent scandals that emerged about
various workhouses, such as reports of starving
residents being forced to eat rotting flesh
just to survive.
Unsurprisingly, as proclaimed by the unnamed
charitable solicitor in A Christmas Carol,
workhouses were places that many “would
rather die” than go.
On this note, the fact that losing one’s
job might have meant having to go to a workhouse
was something that many business owners used
to further exploit their workers.
This brings us to Scrooge’s famous remark,
“If they would rather die, they had better
do it, and decrease the surplus population.”
While this seems to us today to demonstrate
clearly Scrooge was a true villain- not something
a normal person would ever think- this wasn’t
true in Dickens’ day.
Besides the popular idea that poor people
were only poor because of their own vices,
another popular notion was one hinted at by
Reverend Thomas Robert Malthus, in his famed
1798 An Essay on the Principles of Population.
In it, he writes,
The power of population is so superior to
the power of the earth to produce subsistence
for man, that premature death must in some
shape or other visit the human race.
The vices of mankind are active and able ministers
of depopulation.
He further notes, “That the superior power
of population is repressed by moral restraint,
vice and misery…
Yet in all societies, even those that are
most vicious, the tendency to a virtuous attachment
is so strong, that there is a constant effort
towards an increase of population.
This constant effort as constantly tends to
subject the lower classes of the society to
distress and to prevent any great permanent
amelioration of their condition…”
His main overarching point here was that overpopulation
would inevitably lead to lower wages and worsening
work conditions via more workers available,
while simultaneously scarcity of food would
result in said sustenance becoming more expensive.
The ultimate result of all this would be famine
and disease as the population swelled beyond
what could be adequately sustained by available
resources.
Eventually this rise in famine and disease
would then see the population decrease, reducing
instances of famine, disease, etc.
Doing anything to stop the natural population
die-off of the impoverished, like giving widespread
government aid to poor people, would only
serve to make the problem worse for everyone
by keeping more people alive and breeding.
Thus, in his view, laws that sought to help
poor people, in reality, helped no one when
looking at the big picture and, indeed, hurt
society as a whole.
It’s no surprise then that Scrooge’s remark
that it was best for the poor to “die and
decrease the surplus population” is generally
thought to be directed towards many who were
using ideas in Malthus’ Principles of Population
to morally justify not helping those in need
in the present day.
This, of course, is an argument Dickens takes
a moment to explicitly condemn when the Ghost
of Christmas Present states,
Man, if man you be in heart… forbear that
wicked cant until you have discovered What
the surplus is, and Where it is.
Will you decide what men shall live, what
men shall die?
It may be, that in the sight of Heaven, you
are more worthless and less fit to live than
millions like this poor man’s child.
Oh God! to hear the Insect on the leaf pronouncing
there is too much life among his hungry brothers
in the dust!
(Malthus himself was quite disturbed by accusations
from those who felt he was advocating for
an end to all charity and that he was unsympathetic
to the plight of the poor.
He argued that one of his main points was
to try to illustrate the source of the problem
and thus help provide a solution via things
like controlling birth rates and making sure
resources were sufficient to support population
growth before such occurred.)
In any event, Dickens, like many others, was
outraged over what he read in the Report of
the Children’s Employment Commission, and
the Second Report published in 1843- with
the stories perhaps more stinging to him than
most wealthy individuals given his own experiences
as a child laborer.
After all, this would have likely been his
own life-long fate, if not for the inheritance
from his grandmother.
Shortly after reading the Second Report, Dickens
declared to one Dr. Southwood Smith that he
would deliver a “sledge-hammer” blow on
behalf of the Poor Man’s Child.
He soon, however, became convinced that the
best way to do this was not, as he originally
intended, to publish a philosophical pamphlet
on the subject, which he proposed to title
“An Appeal to the People of England on behalf
of the Poor Man’s Child.”
Rather, he decided to write a story illustrating
the points he wished to impart.
On the switch, Dickens wrote to Dr. Smith,
rest assured that when you know [it], and
see what I do, and where and how, you will
certainly feel that a sledge-hammer has come
down with twenty times the force — twenty
thousand times the force I could exert by
following out my first idea.
Even so recently as when I wrote to you the
other day I had not contemplated the means
I shall now, please God, use.
But they have been suggested to me; and I
have girded myself for their seizure— as
you shall see in due time.
This is all set the stage for Dickens penning
his most famous work, which he began writing
in October of 1843, finishing in a mere six
weeks.
The rush in completing the story was both
because he needed money fast and because he
had in mind to make it a Christmas tale.
At the time, Christmas was considered something
of a “second-rate” holiday in much of
Britain.
However, the holiday had begun seeing something
of an upswing in popularity as a festive event
in Britain starting around the early 19th
century- something Dickens was hoping to capitalize
on, leveraging it for a quick burst of sales
to supplement his waning income.
Just as importantly, there was a notion, though
not nearly as popular as after A Christmas
Carol was published, that Christmas should
be a time of charity, which coincided well
with the point he was trying to get across
in the novella.
As Dickens’ himself wrote in A Christmas
Carol (uttered by Fred, Scrooge’s gold-hearted
nephew):
But I am sure I have always thought of Christmas
time, when it has come round–apart from
the veneration due to its sacred name and
origin, if anything belonging to it can be
apart from that–as a good time; a kind,
forgiving, charitable, pleasant time; the
only time I know of, in the long calendar
of the year, when men and women seem by one
consent to open their shut-up hearts freely,
and to think of people below them as if they
really were fellow-passengers to the grave,
and not another race of creatures bound on
other journeys.
And so it was that on December 19, 1843, Charles
Dickens’ A Christmas Carol was published.
The original run of 6,000 copies sold out
by Christmas and the book sold very well beyond,
with 13 official editions published by the
end of the following year.
Unfortunately for Dickens, the profits were
not nearly what he’d initially anticipated.
For reasons not fully clear today (and something
occasionally criticized at the time for, ironically,
pricing the book out of the reach of any among
the poor), he insisted that the physical book
be a prize in and of itself; throwing out
initial plainly bound copies, he stipulated
that the binding must be top-notch with gold
lettering on the spine and front cover.
The pages had to also be gold-gilded, accompanied
by four full-pages of colored hand-etchings,
four woodcut images, and with title pages
printed in bright red and green ink.
All of this came at a high cost, resulting
in the production costs going significantly
over initial projections.
As mentioned, this also priced the book out
of a range that any among the poor could ever
afford, though perhaps Dickens didn’t mind
this; while the book was technically for the
poor in some sense, his target reading audience
on this one was actually those who were a
bit more affluent- perhaps explaining his
choice to spare no expense in the physical
book’s construction to help it appeal more
to the wealthy on look alone.
Whatever his true motivation here, despite
the book selling well, the initial high production
cost left him with a marginal profit of just
£230 off the first run (about £20,000 today),
a number that was reportedly about four times
less than he had expected.
Subsequently, countless counterfeiters published
and sold the story themselves (strong copyright
protection not really being a thing at the
time), further hindering his profits in later
editions, though he would go on to make a
fortune on the book largely thanks to live
readings of the story, which included Dickens
acting out the parts while he read.
While not initially achieving the goal of
solving his financial difficulties (though
it did, at least, help), the book had the
intended effect on the public, with it claimed
in Gentleman’s Magazine in the spring of
1844 that A Christmas Carol was directly responsible
for the significant rise in charitable giving
that occurred in Britain the months following
the publication of the book.
As noted British author G.K.
Chesterton would later proclaim,
The beauty and the real blessing of the story
do not lie in the mechanical plot of it, the
repentance of Scrooge, probable or improbable;
they lie in the great furnace of real happiness
that glows through Scrooge and everything
around him…
Whether the Christmas visions would or would
not convert Scrooge, they convert us…
While nobody knows for sure, as Dickens doesn’t
appear to have mentioned in a form that has
survived through today his reasoning behind
the name “Ebeneezer Scrooge”, it is speculated
that his choice of said name was a very deliberate
one.
To begin with, Scrooge, a name seemingly coined
by Dickens himself, is thought to be derived
from a now antiquated English word “scrouge”
meaning “to squeeze or press”.
Support for this notion is provided in the
opening description of the character, being
someone who was “was a tight-fisted hand
at the grind-stone… a squeezing, wrenching,
graspsing, scraping, clutching, covetous,
old sinner!”
As for the name “Ebeneezer,” the origin
of this name would not have been lost on his
many religious fans.
This is derived from the Hebrew for “stone”
and “helper”- thus the “stone of help”.
In its mention in the Bible, the particular
stone named Eben-haezar was used as a symbol
of remembrance of the Israelites’ defeat
of the Philistines with the help of divine
aid.
Thus, it is speculated that Dickens’ choice
of first name for the character was chosen
perhaps as Scrooge himself was to function
as something of a “stone of remembrance”
for everyone- helping people to remember to
keep a spirit of charity not just on Christmas,
but all year round.
Whether that was Dickens’ intention or not,
another interesting word choice not familiar
to many today outside of this story is the
word “humbug”.
So what’s a humbug?
At the time, this word simply meant something
(or someone) that was an imposter or a fraud.
Hence, when Scrooge called Christmas a humbug,
he was calling the whole idea of the holiday
a fraud.